It's the 8th of May, 2024.
And I am Elisabetta Mori, an historian
of computing currently based in Italy, and
an oral history interview with Fosdem.
Today I'll be talking to Karen M
Sandler.
She's an attorney and the executive director
of Software Freedom Conservancy.
She is known as a cyber lawyer
for her advocacy for free software, particularly
in relation to the software on medical
device.
She was the executive director of the
GNOME Foundation and the general counsel of
the Software Freedom Law Center.
She's also a lecturer in law at
Columbia University.
In 2023, she received an honorary doctorate
from Chi Leuven, Belgium.
And we are recording under story io.
I am in Livorno, Tuscany, Italy and
Karen is in the US.
Okay.
Can you can we start with, you
know, you describing your childhood, your family,
your first encounter with computers?
Sure.
I grew up in the suburbs in
the United States.
Um, my parents had grown up very
poor.
Um, they were the children of, uh,
parents who had fled persecution in Eastern
Europe.
And so they had fled to the
United States, um, with nothing.
Um, and, uh, they, uh, they really
built this life for themselves.
And so they felt this big responsibility
growing up.
Um, and they had a real emphasis
on education and, um, making use of
all of the opportunities that were available
to us.
My father was an engineer and my
mother was a school teacher.
And so together, that made this real
atmosphere with a love of learning and,
um, really just it was a childhood
where, uh, my mother, who was very
interested in archaeology, would take me to
museums constantly and to lectures, and my
father would take me to the planetarium
for lectures on astrophysics.
And, um, he was, uh, more of
like an engineering scientist.
And so, uh, he was quite technical,
and he was one of the first
people using, uh, computer code in order
to, like, using computers to replace the,
um, the manual, um, crunching of numbers.
And so his big contribution to his
field, he was an expert in vibrations,
was to write a computer program that
analyzed vibrations in different mediums.
And so when I was a little
girl, he was constantly working on this
program and on this, um, this analysis.
And it was really fascinating to grow
up with him around the house because
things like, um, you know, when I
was a little girl, I think he
had already it was the very end
of computer punch cards being a thing.
And so they had all of these
computer punch cards that they didn't know
what to do with in his office.
So he brought them home and they
were constantly all over the house.
We used them to take notes when
people called on the phone or to
like, leave little messages for each other.
And so I it's funny because, like,
this was like an ever present part
of my childhood.
And I remember one of my earliest
memories is going to his office with
him as a, as a, as a
little girl and watching the punch cards
fly through the machine and seeing how
I used to imagine the way that
the punches looked were it looked like
animals to me, and I would imagine
the different animals moving.
And I remember, um, I must have
been like, you know, 2 or 3.
And then, um, when I got even
a little older, um, you know, when
I was four, we would play these
really like just old style video games
in his office.
And then of course, because he did
this, he had computers in our house.
So I was very lucky that I
had access to computers and learning how
to use them and, um, and playing
games.
And I mean, I think I wrote
my first really, really, really, really silly
program when I was probably six years
old, you know, or 5 or 6
years old.
Um, I, uh, I think maybe when
I was seven, I was learning, uh,
we learned the, the times tables at
school, and it was a totally a
different time.
The teachers would say, oh, you know,
we're going to do a quiz every
day from this is Friday.
On Monday, we're going to start doing
a quiz every day.
And as soon as you kids learn
like get 100% on this quiz, we'll
move your chair to the opposite side
of the room.
And I said, oh, that has to
be me.
I have to move to the other
side of the room.
And so I went home and I
wrote this little game to test myself
on playing, you know, my times tables.
And I played it all weekend.
I made a little Ascii rocket go
up the screen when I got it
right, and I loved it.
So it was really the first functional
piece of code I ever wrote.
And then on Monday, I went to
school and I felt so bad.
Like in retrospect, I remember the reactions
of the other kids because they just
said, oh, you know, this is starting
on Monday.
And they didn't think about it, but
I got 100% on that because I
had practiced played that game all weekend.
And so I moved to the other
side and it took it took a
couple of days for them to learn
their times tables.
So the other kids came over to
the other side of the room.
But I remember it fondly because, you
know, code coding was like, uh, it
was something that was fun, but it
was also something.
It was a way that I could
do things that I wouldn't otherwise be
able to do.
And so that that was basically my.
And so I grew up really, I
think really fortunately.
And then my like I we were
we were talking before this, Elizabeth you
asked me like what was the first
computer that I remember, um, interacting.
And aside from the, I guess, the
the the punch card situation, the one
that I remember the most from when
I was little at home was we
had this portable computer and it was
like this huge box with a teeny
tiny, like greenish screen and black screen,
and it had a big handle on
it.
So you could, like, carry it like
a huge suitcase.
Um, and so we used to, I,
you know, that we used to, we
used to and the keyboard would like,
you could put the keyboard and attach
it to the, um, to the computer.
So that was pretty cool.
That was pretty cool.
Really?
Yeah.
The portable, you know, they were portable.
You could at least you could move
them because it's until at some point
you couldn't move computer from the big
rooms they were in.
So that was a big, a big,
uh, advancement.
So, um, what, uh, what about education?
What about school?
Which which schools and universities did you
attend?
child?
Well, when I was a kid, I
just went to the the local public
schools for elementary school and, uh, middle
school, although we called it junior high
then and, uh, high school and, um,
and then I went to a school
called Cooper Union for um, for undergraduate,
uh, which is super special because it's
an in the United States, colleges are
very, very expensive.
And, um, it was one of the
it was the only school that was
completely, um, tuition free.
And so, um, and so I went
there and it was amazing.
It was, you know, founded by, like
on the principle that, um, that tuition
should be as free as the air
in the water.
And, um, and it's interesting because Cooper
Union was, um, at one point invited
to become a part of Columbia University,
but because Cooper Union accepted women and
refused to stop accepting women, they couldn't.
They wouldn't be.
They they decided not to join Columbia
University, which is fascinating the way that
the whole history thing went.
So that so that that happened then.
So yeah.
So I went to Cooper Union, which
is where, um, you know, previously there
was no formal computer related education in
my, um, elementary school or my high
school, no computer programming classes, nothing.
Um, and I basically had been doing
a ton of, like, basic programming at
home, um, and just doing whatever I
wanted.
And then when I went to college,
it was very rigorous.
And because I'm old, um, the, uh,
the first class I had to take
in college was, uh, C and Fortran
and Fortran because I went to engineering
school, um, back when again in the
olden days.
And so it was very it was
it was really fun.
And that was like my first, um,
introduction.
And when I got to the school,
the very first thing on the very
first day of my very first class
was to like, get an account in
the computer center, because of course, then
nobody had I, I had a really
like, ridiculous, like notebook computer, as they
called them at the time, which, uh,
which I felt very lucky to have
because nobody really had it, but it
was a castoff from my, my dad,
and it had like, uh, a teeny
tiny amount of ram, like, ridiculously tiny.
But you could you could use it
to, to, uh, to, you know, just
to, to do, um, you know, text
based things.
And so I, I loved it and
I had that at home, but, um,
but nobody else had a computer, so
you had to have, like, an account
so you could use your, um, you
can, you can, um, you you had
your, your workstation and you could log
in.
So I went in to get my,
uh, my account with another, um, woman
who was in the class, uh, in
the incoming class with me.
And we went to the computer center.
And at the computer center, there were,
um, there were no women in the
computer center.
And it was super weird because, uh,
uh, there was actually a guy who
had Ascii Keep porn on his workstation.
And the friend that I was with,
who was my new friend because it
was the first day of college and
we didn't know each other very well,
said, I'm going to come back later.
And she left, and I don't know
what got into me because I'm very,
very shy as a human being like.
And I have some like I'm very
reluctant to to I'm very conflict averse.
Um, but for some reason I was
full of boldness for my first day
of university.
And so I went into the computer
center and I told the, um, Bob
Hopkins, who ran the computer center.
I said to him, you know, it's
really gross out there.
I don't know what you think is
going on out there, but you probably
want to do something about it.
And he said, you're hired.
I said, what?
And he said, you know, like, you're
right, you're right.
You know, I want you to learn.
And then he called in one of
the the guys who worked in the
computer center, and he said, I want
you to, like, just teach her everything.
You know.
I want her to have root as
soon as possible.
And, um, and so I, I worked
in the computer center from the very
beginning of my college, um, experience, and
that was truly amazing.
We installed Linux Labs and, um, and
it was really, you know, I mean,
this is the 90s.
So it was like really early stuff
and, um, and a ton of fun.
And Cooper Union, I got that whole
free education.
I cannot speak more highly.
I think that that was so transformative
for my career.
And the fact that it was ideologically
founded really stuck with me.
I was not a principled person coming
into college.
I didn't really think much about societal
society's problems, but the two have been
such a direct beneficiary of that.
And actually, my father had gone to
Cooper Union, too.
Um, and they they certainly could never
have afforded an education otherwise.
Um, if he hadn't had.
So the fact that that, um, that
that happened and that had such an
impact on my family has really stuck
with me.
And I think that part of why
I'm so focused on public good now
is in part because of how grateful
I am for these structures that helped
me and my family succeed.
So what did you do after graduation?
So after Cooper, I went straight to
law school at Columbia Law School.
Um, and I can't really give you
a good reason why I did that.
I really thought I was going to
do physics grad school.
But, uh, my, uh, my family was,
was sort of, uh, pushing me towards
the law.
Um, just really to find a profession
that was more secure financially, which I
totally respect.
And, um, I thought law could be
interdisciplinary, and, um, it would be fun.
So, um, I got into Columbia Law
School and I went there, which was
really great.
I took a whole variety of classes.
Um, and, uh, and then when I
graduated, I kind of fell into a
corporate law job.
So they have, like, on campus interviewing,
um, and all the law firms come
and they try to recruit.
And at the time, the market was
really booming.
Um, and so there were a lot
of, um, of lucrative corporate opportunities.
And as I said, I wasn't very
civic minded at the time.
Um, and I hadn't really thought too
much about, um, about doing any kind
of public good work.
Um, so I did all this on
campus interviewing, and one of the law
firms said, if you come work for
us because it's a summer internship and
then you get hired for the job
afterwards.
So if the summer internship is the
big thing.
And so they said, if you come
work for us for your summer interview,
we'll let you spend half of the
summer in Hong Kong.
And I was like, you'll work in
our Hong Kong office.
And I was like, yeah, like, I
want to go to Hong Kong.
So.
So that's how I chose to become
a securities lawyer.
I took that summer internship and I
had such a good time doing it.
Um, when I was in Hong Kong,
in the office, the law firm announced
that they were merging with an English
law firm called Clifford Chance, and they
were merging with a US law firm.
And the people in the Hong Kong
office said, You don't really want to
work for those like we don't know
anything about that other law firm.
They're, you know, they're doing their own
thing.
You want to stay with us.
So we're going to recommend that you
start working in London.
And I was like, ooh, London sounds
nice.
So, uh, yeah.
So I wound up starting my career
in the London office of Clifford Chance
as a cross-border securities lawyer doing transactional
work.
And, um, and that was great because
I was able to bring my technical
background to help evaluate these all of
these technological companies that were very large.
And, um, I really enjoyed it.
I moved back to the New York
office, um, and the partner I worked
for, uh, shifted over to another law
firm called Gibson Dunn, which was really
fantastic.
And so I switched over with him,
and most of my clients were in
Brazil, and I really enjoyed that for
a while.
And then I was sort of like,
ah, I don't really know.
Um, like, this isn't really for me
for the long term.
Um, and I was starting to reevaluate
my, um, my situation.
And so, um, and so I was
one of the first people at the
law firm to quit with nothing lined
up.
It's like super common now, um, I
think this is one of those being
an xennial kind of situations was that
people didn't really do that before us,
but, um, so I did that and
it was sort of, uh, um, it
was it caused a lot of like,
waves because people were talking about, oh,
did you hear that?
Karen quit with nothing lined up just
because she was, you know, the partner
I worked for was starting to use
his political capital to help me make
partner, and I just didn't want him
to have to do that because I
knew I didn't want to make partner.
So I.
I gave a very long period of
notice.
I let him choose.
So I worked for six more months,
and then I was going to take
a, I was going to take another
six months off before I started looking
for a job.
But then I heard that the Software
Freedom Law Center was hiring.
The founder, Eben Moglen, had, uh, been
my professor in law school, and so
he asked me if I wanted to,
apply there because he he knew I
was technical and we had, um, you
know, I'd been in his class and
so that's how I wound up at
the Software Freedom Law Center even before
I wanted to start looking.
So I got very, very, very lucky.
And I was someone who really thought
that.
I really thought that open source was
cool.
As I said, in college, I installed
those Linux labs.
I really thought that it was a
neat thing, but I did not think
that I, I didn't really think too
much about the societal implications of it
or, or what it might mean for
me, but I still felt so lucky
to have landed in such a cool
job.
So, um, this was 2005, 2006?
Yeah, I think it was 2005.
2005.
And you work for the Software Freedom
Law Center from 2005 to 2011?
Well, it's such a neat job because
I met so many amazing developers and
I heard from them, You know why
they contributed?
Why they were so passionate about free
and open source software.
You know, whether it was the folks
that were, um, you know, really the
the copyleft advocates, the folks working at
the Free Software Foundation or people who
were passionate about the collaboration component, like
the folks that were my clients at
the Apache Software Foundation.
And then, um, most interestingly, perhaps, was
my where my clients like the ones,
um, at X.Org, um, who were really
when I met them, were very adamant
about, um, being non-copyleft that permissive licensing
was an ideological choice.
In other words, not trying to have,
um, you know, making sure you don't
have that reciprocal component to the licensing.
Um, who over the course of this,
of my career that there's one developer
in particular, Keith Packard, who came completely
around and now is a very strong
copyleft advocate because he was burned so
many times, um, from having his code
be, uh, be proprietary.
So it's really, really fascinating.
But hearing from those developers directly about
their legal problems, helping them, incorporating their
organizations, becoming like a really big part
of their organization, um, and what they
were doing meant that I got to
I got to learn why they were
doing it.
And um, and the philosophy and it
really started to sink in.
And then while I was at the
Software Freedom Law Center, I found out
that I had a heart condition that
I was born with.
Um, it's called hypertrophic cardiomyopathy.
It means that I have a big
and really thick heart, but it's like,
uh, mine is particularly thick.
It's, uh, it's like about three times
the size of parts of it are
about three times the size of a
normal person's heart.
And it was totally fine.
I didn't have any symptoms.
I happened to find out about it
somewhat accidentally because I was getting migraine
headaches.
Neurologists, they heard I had a murmur.
Anyway, so I found out about my
heart condition In and um, and the,
the main thing about it was that
I needed to get an implanted pacemaker
defibrillator just for the defibrillator part so
that, um, because I was at a
very high risk of sudden death.
And so, um, like, being technical and
being diagnosed with this condition and knowing
that I need to, to get a
device, it made me research the device.
And I really wanted to learn about
the software on the device.
And I hit a complete dead end
in my research where, um, the companies
had were not able to share any
of the information with me to help
me understand how my own defibrillator would
work.
And it was funny because talking to
the doctors, um, you know, just I
just asked them, you know, what do
you know?
What can you tell me about the
software in this device?
And my the first electrophysiologist I had,
his response was software.
Like, what are you talking about?
And I explained, this device is run
by like there's software on the device.
It's critical to how it operates.
And he had he had no idea.
He was like, no, it just works.
He's like, no, there's there's details here
you probably should worry about.
And then, um, he called the, you
know, the device representative, the technician, the
tech representative who was there at the
moment.
I got lucky in the office and
that representative said software.
So it was this funny, like, you
know, it was a long time ago
and, um, I think people hadn't really
thought very much about software.
And so I was, I think the
introduction to these issues, uh, the electrophysiologist
that I was working with, got so
upset when I started to explain the
things that could go wrong with software
that, um, and why I was so
nervous about it.
This is on a follow up phone
call, and I explained why I really
wanted this information.
And, um, he got so upset that
he hung up on me because he
implanted, you know, sometimes multiple defibrillators on
a single day.
And I think the idea of anyone
asking questions about its safety and efficacy
implied that somehow he wasn't doing a
good job.
But, you know, it was a really
interesting education for me.
It was a very bleak moment and
very upsetting.
But, um, but I realized that the
way we think about software as human
beings and as professionals is, is, is
really different than the way that the
technology actually works and what we can
rely on.
So I really thought that, um, I
became really passionate and really convinced that
we need to be able to audit
the software.
We rely on the idea that there
would be software in my body, implanted
in my body, and screwed into my
heart was and that I wouldn't be
able to see it was just completely
baffling, just completely baffling.
And so it caused me to really
advocate for the transparency of these devices.
I wrote a paper.
Um, you know, I started doing, uh,
other work.
I filed Freedom of Information Act requests
with the medical device manufacturers to see
what I could find.
I mostly hit brick walls, but the
advocacy component was really important.
And, um.
And as I lived with my defibrillator,
I, um, I had other circumstances that
made me realize that it wasn't just
about transparency, so.
So I did all this work at
the Software Freedom Law Center.
I know you're trying to get some
narrative of my my timeline here.
So so I kept working at the
Software Freedom Law Center.
I became general counsel there.
Um, and, um, I still provided legal
advice to the clients of the Software
Freedom Law Center, which were really amazing
organizations in and of themselves.
And, um, and over time, um, one
of those clients recruited me to be
their executive director.
So I went over to the GNOME
Foundation, and GNOME is, um, is desktop
software.
So if you're running a Linux machine.
The most common desktop is GNOME, and
so they had just launched GNOME three,
which was this.
Really it's the it's the format of
GNOME now and it's just really shiny
and beautiful.
And they needed someone to come in
and and help push the foundation forward.
And so they recruited me.
And so I went over there and
um, and while I was working at
the Gnome Foundation, I had, um, I
was pregnant and I was set to
have, um, to have a baby.
And while I was pregnant, my heart
palpitated, which happens to about like a
third of all pregnant people, there's like,
you know, a third of all pregnancies.
You or maybe something like that.
It's super, super common.
Um, your heart, like, beats a little
bit faster, has palpitations.
Um, when I give this talk in
a whole room, all the women are
usually, like, nodding their heads.
Um, and it would be fine if
you were pregnant and went to the
doctor and said.
I've had my heart beating.
Funny.
They'll say, oh, you're pregnant, it's palpitations.
Let us know if you pass out
or if you feel lightheaded.
Right.
And none of those things happen to
me except that I had a defibrillator.
And my defibrillator thought my heart was
in a dangerous rhythm.
And even though I didn't need it
to, it shocked me unnecessarily.
Repeatedly.
And the only way I could get
it to stop shocking me was to
take medication that slowed my heart rate
down so much that it was hard
to climb up a flight of stairs.
And being pregnant was a temporary condition.
I've done it twice.
The babies are fine.
Like it all worked out great.
But I it was really, really eye
opening because it really stood for the
proposition that our technology may not be
made for us.
Device manufacturers desperately don't want pregnant patients
getting shocked.
What a nightmare that is.
Definitely not what they want.
But only 15% of defibrillators go to
people under the age of 65.
So the number of people who are
pregnant with defibrillators are teeny, teeny, teeny
tiny.
So yeah.
So that's you know, it just stands
for the proposition of like our technology
may not be made for us.
And what will we do when it
fails?
So, um.
Yeah, that's, uh.
Yes.
Your story puts us on mute for
one second.
I'm sorry.
So your story made me, uh, you
know, at the beginning, we discussed also,
this made me think of, um, Marimo,
who, you know, and wrote also a
nice article with about her pacemaker and
how her, as a someone who is
an expert in cybersecurity, realized how, you
know, uh, vulnerable she was by having
some medical implants.
Um, so This is make me making
me think also a lot about.
So this was something that happened to
you in 2006.
Now almost 20 years have passed.
How do you see, uh, everything around
around implanted medical devices.
About.
Around what?
You, as you call yourself cyborg.
So what's the current state?
So it's so the defibrillator.
I got that 20 years ago, but
the pregnancy happened later.
So it's been this like.
And so it's a really fascinating to
me is that I previously thought it
was only about transparency and auditability.
Then I realized that it was all
about, um, control.
And you know, who has control over
the software that is that we, that
we fundamentally rely on, right.
And then, um, and then most recently
last year, as is typical with my
heart condition, I wound up getting an
irregular heartbeat.
Um, it happened to my dad from
when he was 32.
I was a little older.
Um, but it's quite common.
And all of a sudden, I needed
to know when I got an irregular
rhythm and if it was safe to
travel because I had an important trip.
I was getting an honorary doctorate from
Calvin, and I really didn't want to
miss that, because that's kind of a
once in a lifetime thing.
But I got this irregular rhythm and
had to travel two days later.
And do you know that because the
device manufacturers representative was out of town
visiting family in India and they did
not have an alternate person, I could
not get my defibrillator interrogated.
And all of this major metropolitan city
that I live in, wild stuff.
And I have this defibrillator, um, in
particular, because while it's, um, it's a
large defibrillator in.
Sorry, it's a large manufacturer in Europe.
It's, um, it has a much smaller
imprint in the United States, but I
use them because, um, these devices are
totally interference.
They can be, um, you know, they
they researchers have shown that they can
be, um, you can run their batteries
down.
You can have them shock unnecessarily because
they're all broadcasting remotely.
And, um, and the encryption on these
devices has historically been terrible.
There have been improvements lately, but, uh,
but really just awful stuff.
And so I found this one manufacturer
where you could disable the, the broadcasting
and software and the, the others all
just stay broadcasting consistently.
So at least with my defibrillator, you
have to they call it like a
programmer.
You have to at least be right
on top of me in order to
read it, and I'll be able to
see it, whereas with all of the
other ones, or if or if this
one, if you enable the, um, the
radio telemetry, you could be all the
way across the street.
And as I said, I live in
a major city.
So like it's so densely packed, the
person could be anywhere and interfere with
these devices.
So I need this manufacturer.
Um, and we may get to the
fact that I run a diversity initiative,
um, for folks subject to systemic bias,
but because of some of my work,
it makes some people very angry.
And I think just being a very
prominently like just a prominent woman in
technology, it means that, um, I have
a lot of unpleasant experiences, which includes,
uh, people, uh, who want to enter,
like who I've got.
I'll just say I've gotten rape and
death threats.
And so it's not theoretical to be
worried about somebody interfering with my defibrillator.
So I really needed to get the
device.
However, it meant that I'm beholden to
this one company.
None of these devices are interoperable.
You can't use the interrogator from one
device to read the information off of
another.
And so I was completely unable to
get the information off of my defibrillator
in my own city.
And, um, and then I was in
Belgium for the, um, for the honorary
doctorate, and I was able to go
to a Brussels hospital, and they were
able to interrogate my device and get
the information off.
But it was just this horrifying moment
of being so helpless because not only
could I not see the code in
my own body, not only could I
have no control over it when it
was, uh, when it was inappropriately shocking
me and I needed to take unnecessary
medication to stop that.
But also, I couldn't get the very
information that I needed to make really
important choices about whether it was safe
for me to travel or how it
was safe for me to live my
life.
So, you know, having this, it's been
like every I'd say like 5 to
7 years.
There's like some other major lesson in
technology that I'm learning from living with
this defibrillator.
And now I have a second.
So this is my second defibrillator.
The first one lasts to ten years.
My current defibrillator, they predict to live
17 years to exist for 17 years.
And when you think about the life
of our technology, 17 years is such
a long time.
We don't even know what the world
will be like in 17 years, let
alone, I mean, much of our technology
becomes obsolete in just a couple of
years.
So the idea that we're making these
choices that we're going to have to
live with societally for a long time
is really important.
And at the same time, I realized
that this technology that is sewn into
my body is a metaphor for all
of the other software we rely on.
It's not really about medical devices so
much as it's about everything that is
critical in our society, whether it's our
stock markets, our, um, you know, our
basic infrastructure, uh, the, the stuff we
rely on to educate, um, our kids
like our, our, our, you know, technology
that we use for our banking and
for, uh, and for our basic communications,
like, and we're combining everything with everything
else, and we're only as safe as
our weakest link.
So I'd say that all of the
things that I talked about, it's now
almost 20 years ago, I thought a
lot of what I said felt really,
you know, theoretical and space agey.
Um, and it felt like it was
very unlikely for that to, I don't
know, it just felt so theoretical.
Every passing year becomes the reality of
what we live in, and every year
it becomes more and more critical that
we take control over our society, of
our software as a society.
And unfortunately, what's happened is that over
time, while we have more open source,
the more open source and everything, there's
Foss, you know, there's the Linux kernel
is in everything.
It's in refrigerators and toasters.
And, you know, we use it.
You can no one would ever imagine
launching a business without using free and
open source software that economists just valued
it at a ridiculously huge at at
a, at a value that is more
than, um, than the value of Microsoft
for example.
So by a lot.
And so like it's so critical.
But the freedom we have the choice
the you know, the control over our
technology is so much less than what
we've ever had before.
It is near impossible to get along,
like to replace the software on any
device that you own.
It's impossible to repair the software on
devices that you own.
And our ability as a society to
move from one product to another is
almost negligible.
It's, um, astounding to me at this
very moment.
Um, just recently in the United States,
the United States passed a nonpartisan, bipartisan
bill to, uh, to require the sale
of, of of TikTok in the United
States to a US entity which solves
none of the problems that, you know,
like, it doesn't actually create any ethical
technology.
So people are waking up to this
idea that there's a problem with our
technology and that we need to be,
you know, we need to be doing
things differently.
But they they don't know how yet.
And what we need is software freedom.
What we need is decentralization.
What we need is encryption.
But these problems are hard and they
require activity on a mass level.
We need to have a lot of
group like group collective action.
And that is that that takes that
takes work and that takes money, and
it takes the inconvenience of the business
models of companies in the tech sector,
all of which are.
So I would say, like if you're
asking me how I feel about it
now, with respect to looking back, I'd
say I am more right than I
ever wanted to be.
And, um, which really saddens me.
And, um, and the state of our
technology is so much worse than I
expected it would be now.
But at the same time, I have
so much more hope than I've ever
had before, because I think that people
are starting to get the fact that
something's wrong and they're understand the fact
that our technology is so important that
we can't just sit by and let
companies subjugate our own digital rights to
their quarterly profits.
Thank you.
So, um, let's go back to the
time you were working for the Gnome
Foundation.
Um, in 2012, you got married, but
at the same time, another important activity
there was, like, you also worked, uh,
at gnome, uh, in the outreach program
for women.
So, uh, can you talk about those
years and, um, what brought you to
work for the Software Freedom Conservancy a
few years later?
So the GNOME actually started outreach program
for women when I was at the
Software Freedom Law Center, and they asked
Sflc for legal help in setting it
up.
So I've been involved with, uh, and
other lawyers were more of the primary
contacts on that.
But I've been involved in, um, in
this program since its inception, which is
pretty exciting.
Um, and it started in 2010.
Um, and it started because I was
participating in a program called Google Summer
of code.
And Google Summer of code is an
internship program that Google runs for open
source projects where, um where students are
allowed to get these, they get these
paid internships where they work remotely for
a few months.
And at GNOME, they had 181 applicants,
and none of them appeared to be
women.
And so my good friend Marina was
tapped to, um, to kind of look
and figure out whether there was.
Well, actually, there was another program in
2006 that was started then, but then
nothing happened with it.
And then in 22,009, Marina was tapped
to sort of like she was very
involved with the Gnome Foundation.
She was a gnome shell developer, and
she was tapped to to create something
to help with this.
And so she came up, she re
revamped that whole program and launched an
outreach program for women, um, which started
with six interns, um, in 2010, um,
working um on various aspects of GNOME
and I came over as executive director
and it was just, you know, whatever
the professional equivalent of love at first
sight was.
And Marina, um, we jumped into it
together and we immediately started building the
program together.
We expanded it to other communities, um,
and, uh, and, uh, and slowly grew
it.
And, um, I had been a, um,
a co-founder of the Software Freedom Conservancy
from when I was at the Software
Freedom Law Center.
Um, I was the one who filed
the incorporation papers and, um, uh, and
it was an initiative of the Software
Freedom Law Center to launch Software Freedom
Conservancy.
And so I had been a volunteer
throughout the time I was at GNOME
and Software Freedom Conservancy, which is a
fiscal sponsor.
It's the umbrella organization, and it's the
home of many free and open source
software projects.
Uh, it also, uh, we do three
different branches, which I guess I'll explain
in a, in a little bit, but,
um, but Software Freedom Conservancy was actually
the first, uh, organization that wound up
participating with its twisted project in outreach
program for women early, and we realized
we could expand it.
We expanded to Linux kernel.
Um, and soon the program was a
larger program, um, where we expanded its
criteria.
Um, we ultimately renamed it as Outreachy.
And, um, now we um, uh, now,
uh, we, we provide internships not just
to women, uh, and actually not all
women now, because the program is only
open to people who are subject to
systemic bias and are impacted by The
representation.
So we seek essays from people and
they tell us, like, we don't presume
to understand all of the discrimination and
systemic bias that's out there in the
world.
So we have our applicants tell us,
and the essay is not graded based
on how beautifully it's written, or even
if the person uses correct grammar and
spelling.
For us, it's just we want to
hear about people's experiences with their own,
um, how they're impacted by systemic bias
and impacted by discrimination.
And now we've run the program all
of this time.
And, uh, um, it's it's been an
amazing journey.
And Noam launched outreach program for women,
but as it was rebranded into Outreachy,
um, and as it, uh, as it
grew, it moved over to Software Freedom
Conservancy.
And it was funny because I had
already left GNOME as executive director and
came over to Software Freedom Conservancy as
executive director, kind of swapping my volunteer
role for my professional role and vice
versa.
So I became a volunteer for GNOME,
and I joined its board of directors
as a volunteer, and my executive director
role was with Software Freedom Conservancy, um,
which was which was super fun.
And then, uh, and then on the
same path at the same time, Outreachy
moved from GNOME to Software Freedom Conservancy.
And it was fun because I basically
said, well, I can't be part of
that decision because I'm completely conflicted.
I'm on the board of directors of
GNOME, but I'm executive director of Software
Freedom Conservancy.
And so Marina handled that evaluation herself.
And we I lined up lawyers directly
to advise, to advise Outreachy and to
advise Software Freedom Conservancy.
Um, and so we had um, it
was it was a really interesting little
thing.
And then in 2014, I think it
was, uh, outreachy moved over to Software
Freedom Conservancy, where it is now.
And so Software Freedom Conservancy is my
absolute dream job.
I call myself the luckiest cyborg lawyer
in the world.
Um, because the main three things that
our organization does is we, um, as
I said, we're a fiscal sponsor, so
we recognize that no one can leave
using proprietary software if there's nothing to
switch to.
So we help support the creation of
free and open source software.
Then we have a second what we
our logo is a tree.
So we talk about our branches.
So our second branch is Outreachy where
we provide these opportunities.
Um, because our software will never be
made for everyone if it's not made
by everyone.
And a good example of that is
the way my defibrillator shocked me, because
I was not part of the anticipated
use case.
Right?
There are all these great little videos
that were flying around Twitter.
Once upon a time where they were
like soap dispensers and, um, you see
a person with a light colored hand,
a light skinned hand put their hand
under the soap dispenser and soap comes
out as you would expect it to.
And then someone with dark skin puts
their hand under the very same soap
dispenser, and nothing happens until they put
a white paper towel on top of
their hand and the soap comes out.
And it really, it's just very clear
that there was no one on the
team that made and tested that soap
dispenser who had dark skin.
So until you make your technology diversely,
you probably won't make.
You won't be able to anticipate all
of the use cases that are happening,
even still.
Technology needs to be changeable.
It needs to evolve over time, but
you won't stand a chance if you're
just making it with a small group
of people.
So that's our second branch.
And then our third branch is standing
up for, um, for copyleft, which as
I explained earlier, it's sort of the,
um, this fun licensing regime where instead
of using copyright to keep software a
monopolized small, you know, monopolized way to
extract royalties from people.
Instead, you use that copyright, but to
require sharing.
And so it's, uh, detractors used to
call it viral, but, uh, but it's,
uh, uh, you know, a forever free
model, and, um, and it it it
what's neat about copyleft is it is
actually a software right to repair.
So it basically gives millions of people
rights to fix their devices.
It gives you the right to ask
for, um, for the source code.
And especially if you look at one
of the most popular copyleft licenses, GPL,
the GPL v2.
In that license, it says that they
must provide not just the complete and
corresponding source code, but including complete and
corresponding source code, including the scripts to
control compilation and installation.
So you must be able to replace
your software.
You must be able to repair it.
And that's really that's our third.
Our third chapter.
We do things like, um, we filed
a lawsuit against the television manufacturer Vizio,
which is a very large TV manufacturer
in the United States.
Because they were not following the rules,
they weren't making their complete and corresponding
source code available.
And so, um, when they didn't respond
to us asking them very nicely, we
filed a lawsuit as a consumer, as
a purchaser of devices, because they are
the ones who know that the device
is not in compliance and also have
an acute need for it.
These TVs surveil us.
They collect a lot of information about
us, and they also could be useful
to do other things than what the
device manufacturers think we should be using
them for.
And because of these licenses, we have
a right to that software.
So we're trying to connect the dots
on on copyleft and how critical that
is to the things that that folks
do.
And so I'm really feel super lucky
to work at Software Freedom Conservancy.
Thank you.
Um, you also got several, uh, awards.
Um, in 2011, the O'Reilly Open Source
Award, in 2017, the Free Software Award
for your work promoting software freedom, and
in 2023 the honorary doctor in Belgium
at Katholieke Universiteit Leuven.
And you were, uh, you You mentioned
it earlier, but, um, can you tell,
uh, can you tell us, uh, first,
did you expect it?
No.
It was a huge surprise.
Um, and it's probably the most meaningful,
like those other awards.
Very nice.
Um, you know, as an adult, you
don't really have the opportunity for people
to say good job to, like, get
recognition for what you do.
So they were very meaningful to me.
But, um, but for the, um, for
the Kai Levin honorary doctorate, it was
a total surprise.
And the best thing about it is
that it was the students who decided
I should get it.
So they do five per year, four
are nominated by faculty, and they're usually,
um, folks that are working on things
that the academics at Kai Levin are
building on from their work, for example.
Um, and then the fifth one is
the students nominated, and it's a 60
000 student university.
So presumably some of the students want
to give it to, you know, like
Taylor Swift.
So like or somebody like that.
So what was really neat about it
was that, um, it reflected the fact
that there were students at the school
who understood the value of free and
open source software and understood how important
the concept of software freedom is, then
that they had encountered my work and
that they found it interesting and inspiring
and that they wanted to collaborate with
the movement was really, really huge.
And then the fact that the students
that didn't know about it, which presumably
was most of them, that they could
understand why the work was important and
that it was important and that they
cared about it, I think was the
most incredible thing.
Um, I've done a lot of, you
know, interviews over the years.
There have been, um, articles and documentaries
in most of those works.
There's something wrong.
There's some fact that's wrong.
Some like some thing that they didn't
quite get right about what the work
stood for, or even just some basic
fact.
But in the movie that they made
and in the the explanations that they
gave about why they wanted to give
me the award, they got everything 100%
right.
And I was so struck by that
because they really took the time.
And what it stands for, for me,
is the fact that something has fundamentally
changed, that young people care about the
state of their software, they care about
who's making it.
They care about what it will mean
for their lives down the road.
And it, you know, and and also
what they think is valuable that they
want to spend their time.
And when I give a lecture around
the, um, the doctorate, um, there was
great participation from folks in the law
school, in the engineering school, in computer
science.
So it was just it was it
was really, I'd say, one of the
most meaningful things because it made me
feel like I'm not just on a
hamster wheel.
Like I'm not just shouting into a
void.
Um, trying to get things to change.
That will never change.
But in fact stands for the fact
that they will change because smart young
people care about it.
Smart older people also care about it.
And they're retiring like we're about to
like we're about to have this explosion
of productivity.
And it's I just can't I just
can't wait.
It's such an exciting time in software
freedom and in technology in general, because
while we've created this massive dystopia, we're
finally in the change the part where
things can change.
Um, so if you look about at
the future, um, what are the things
that you can see that are going
in the right direction?
And what are the things that we
really need to be careful about?
Yeah, I mean, I'd say like.
It's funny because one of the things
I'm most proud of, of my career
is the fact that we had more
than a thousand students come through the
outreach program.
Um, like all these opportunities for folks
that are subject to systemic bias who
wouldn't ordinarily be included.
And I think that the like software
freedom stands for the proposition that we
can democratize our technology, but in effect,
we haven't really done that very much.
Um, you know, most of our technology
creation is very homogeneous, and it's done
by a very centralized small group of
companies.
So looking forward, what what I want
to what I, what I'm hoping to
see is this explosion of contributions from
folks who have had enough, you know,
who are willing to like it's really
hard to change what you do.
It's really hard if you're used to
certain, you know, if you're used to
having certain apps or features on your
phone or on your computer.
It's really hard to go back, but
people are willing to, you know, um,
one of my kids is now 11
and like quite a few kids now
have flip phones and are happy for
it.
They've read the articles saying that social
media causes, uh, depression in teenagers.
They've read the fact that screens and
the use of smartphones interfere with their
brain development.
And they don't they don't.
They don't want it.
That's what foreign grown ups do.
And they don't want it anymore.
Right.
So looking forward, I think that, um,
you know, the sharing of information where
we're able to critically look at where
we're we are a data like a
data driven society where we look for,
you know, uh, concrete aggregation of information
about the impact of technology and where,
um, we're seeing what doesn't work.
We are seeing an increase in a
willingness to regulate.
I was astounded that GDPR was able
to happen in Europe.
And so happy and grateful.
And I think we're going to be
able to I think we're going to
see more regulation.
But the downside is that there's a
contraction of funding across the board.
There's less money coming into software freedom.
And there was a co-option of the
software freedom movement by companies that were
wanting to extract the value of open
source.
And so we're going to have to
get over this, and we're going to
get over this through a really catastrophic
I mean, it really looks like we're
in this catastrophic time where funding is
contracting.
Companies did massive layoffs.
They're very focused on their profit centers.
And so I think things are going
to get worse before they get better.
But I think through all that pain,
I think we'll emerge on the other
side with a willingness to have more,
um, you know, the societal collaborations that
we need for our software.
And I think this, you know, well,
it'll be very interesting to see what
happens with generative AI.
Um, you know, and when when that
bubble likely bursts, that'll be a really
interesting, um, you know, situation to see.
So, you know, there's it'll it'll be
it'll be fascinating.
And I hope that, um, you know,
I'm sort of in the middle of
my career and I'm hoping that I
can be a part of I can
I can hold out long enough to
be a part of the real, of
the real change where things actually get
a lot better.
Uh, is there anything you would like
to add that we haven't covered today?
I would say that if you are
able, you should donate to these causes
that you care about.
Where software freedom Conservancy.
So SF Conservancy org.
Please, please, please sign up as a
sustainer.
But the situation is getting dire across
all of the nonprofits in our space.
Our technology has never been more fragile,
and we need both the advocacy and
the technology creation.
So if you feel you could do
that, you should also speaking up.
Um, it's becoming much harder to stand
up to discrimination and systemic bias.
Lots of companies, for example, have cut
their, um, their funding for because they
don't want to support anybody's woke agenda,
which I completely understand.
But it does mean that these opportunities
there are fewer and far between for
people to get involved.
So getting engaged, you know, I think
is is really important.
And I know this is meant to
be archival.
So it's like living I'm talking in
this moment of time.
And I'm hoping that in the long
run, you people of the future will
say, ha ha, what an interesting time
it was in the 2020s, and now
we've solved so many of these problems,
and I, I hope we have, uh,
but I guess the, the main thing
about, about our particular time is that
we all need to get it's so
dire that every single individual needs to
get involved, and it needs to happen
now.
So we are almost done.
Uh, but I hope we have other
chances to chat again.
Maybe on Thursday.
Uh, one last question.
So at your website, punk rock.
Com it says you're available as a
DJ.
Are you still available?
Oh, boy.
I you know, I was actually just
asked to DJ this past, uh, I
was asked to DJ for an event
in August.
I maybe, maybe I it's very fun.
So I, I haven't done it in
a little while, so I'm kind of
rusty.
Okay, okay.
So, um, I hope we'll have another
chance to chat again soon.
And thank you for now, and it's
been a real pleasure talking to you
today.
Thank you very much for what you're
doing.
Thank you.
Elizabeth.
I'm so happy to be here.
Thank you.